corporate raiders were the stars of Wall
Street in the 1980s the new generation
of troublemakers for chief executives
are activist investors activist
shareholders targeted the largest number
of companies ever in 2018 a record 226
companies based activists campaigns one
way to imagine activists is as the
populace of Finance these investors
usually hedge funds build small stakes
in a company where they believe the
share price can perform better in the
name of shareholder democracy they
demand their voice for change be heard
or else the activists toolkit for
seeking these changes is diverse but in
general they are looking to shake up a
company to boost its stock price that
could mean pushing for divestment or
demanding that it should explore a sale
if they don't get their way they will
seek to replace a chief executive a
board member or even a majority of the
board the first approach between an
activist and management is usually
private perhaps through a letter if the
company doesn't comply or respond
adequately the activists will look to
take their demands public and that is
when things can get ugly measures taken
might include media campaigns to
discredit management or board members
some of the Masters of the activist
universe are Paul singer of Elliot
management Jeff Alban of value act
Nelson Peltz of trying partners and Carl
Icahn originally a corporate raider each
professes to have their own unique style
but either way these strategies are
proliferating in 2018 activists deployed
the most capital ever the amount
invested in targets reached a high of 65
billion dollars with that money they've
won a record number of board seats in
target companies and the trend is not
stopping activist investors have
historically focused on mid-sized US
companies that's partly because they're
the ones that are easier to target with
fewer tools to defend themselves but
large funds are increasingly going after
bigger and bigger targets and expanding
their reach to Europe and Asia we should
expect more and more audacious activist
campaigns in
to come as the appetite for corporate
change is far from waning
[Music]